>> THE VERDICT OF THIS KANGAROO
COURT WILL BE MEANINGLESS.
SPEAK OF THE STAIN WILL ALWAYS
BE ON HIS PRESIDENCY.
>> Laura: CHUCK SCHUMER
CALLING THE SENATE A KANGAROO
COURT.
RIPPING UP PAPERS IN THE HOUSE
AND THEN HE GOT THE KANGAROO
COURT IN THE SENATE.
NICE JOB.
TRY TO ME NOW, LINDSEY GRAHAM,
CHAIRMAN OF THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
SENATOR, THIS IS NOT A TRUE
ACQUITTAL, THEY ARE SAYING.
>> ALL I CAN SAY IS THAT
SENATOR SCHUMER AND NANCY PELOSI
ARE NO LONGER IN CHARGE OF THIS.
WHY DID SHE TEAR UP THE SPEECH,
AND NANCY PELOSI CUSTOMER WHO
WAS HER AUDIENCE?
IT WAS THE SQUAD.
SHE’S LOST CONTROL OF THE HOUSE,
SENATOR SCHUMER IS GOING TO GET
PRIMARY BY AOC.
THE PEOPLE WE USED TO WORK WITH,
THEY’VE LOST THEIR MIND WHEN IT
COMES TO TRUMP.
THE PRESIDENT WAS ACQUITTED,
THIS WAS A RIDICULOUS ACCUSATION
AGAINST THE PRESIDENCY ITSELF
AND OUR COLLEAGUES VOTED FOR A
KID CONVICTION.
I THINK YOU PUT THE PRESIDENCY
AT RISK.
I DON’T QUESTION YOUR MOTIVES
BUT I SURE QUESTION YOUR
JUDGMENT.
>> Laura: YOU THINK
MITT ROMNEY IS REPRESENTING HIS
PEOPLE?
70% OF PEOPLE IN HIS STATE IN
FAVOR HIS ACTION.
>> HE VOTED NOT GUILTY ON THE
PROCESS ARGUMENT, OBSTRUCTION OF
CONGRESS.
THEY IMPEACHED THE PRESIDENT FOR
DARING TO GO TO COURT, THEY
IMPEACHED THE PRESIDENT WITH 78
DAYS, HE NEVER GOT A CALL A
WITNESS, NEVER GOT A CROSS
EXAMINE ANYBODY.
YOU COULDN’T GET A PARKING
TICKET BASED ON THE PROCESS THEY
USED.
HERE’S ABUSE OF POWER, THEY’RE
GOING TO REMOVE THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES BECAUSE HE
SUSPENDED MILITARY AID TO THE
UKRAINE FOR A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME TO LEVERAGE AN
INVESTIGATION THAT NEVER
OCCURRED.
THEY GOT THE MONEY AND THERE WAS
NO INVESTIGATION, AND THEY WERE
GOING TO IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT
BASED ON THAT, THAT IS
RIDICULOUS.
>> Laura: "THE FEDERALIST"
REPORTED THAT A TOP ROMNEY
ADVISOR SERVED ON THE BOARD OF
BURISMA WITH HUNTER BIDEN.
HE JOINED BURISMA’S BOARD OF
DIRECTORS WHILE HUNTER WAS ALSO
SERVING ON THE BOARD.
CUTE LITTLE COINCIDENCE, DON’T
YOU THINK?
>> I’M NOT GOING TO SAY THAT
THAT BOAT IS SINKING.
>> Laura: ISN’T THAT SWAMPY?
>> ALL I CAN SAY IS WE ARE GOING
TO LOOK AT HUNTER BIDEN.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO LIVE IN A
WORLD WHERE YOU TAKE A WRECKING
BALL TO THE TRUMP FAMILY AND YOU
CAN’T ASK HUNTER BIDEN, BY THE
WAY, THE FOREIGN RELATIONS
COMMITTEE WILL, I HOPE, THEY
SHOULD.
JIM RISCH, IF YOU LISTEN, YOU
NEED TO ASK JOHN KERRY’S CHIEF
OF STAFF, WHAT DID YOU DO ABOUT
THE EMAIL WHEN YOU WERE TOLD
THERE WAS A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST?
I’M GOING TO CALL EVERYBODY WHO
SIGNED THE FISA WARRANT, I HOPE
RACHEL BYRD WILL TELL US WHO THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER IS AND WAS THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER WORKING WITH
POLITICAL OPERATIVES ON SCHIFF’S
STAFF CUSTOMER AND I DON’T KNOW,
WE WILL LOOK.
IF HAND REPUBLICAN HAD DONE THIS
THEY WOULD BE LOOKING AT US.
>> Laura: HOW ABOUT THE IG?
>> I WANT TO KNOW WHO WAS THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER, WHAT WAS THEIR
MOTIVATION, DID THEY HAVE A
POLITICAL BIAS, WERE THEY
WORKING WITH PEOPLE WHO WANTED
TO TAKE TRUMP DOWN EARLY ON HIS
PRESIDENCY.
>> Laura: ARE YOU GOING TO
CALL THE WHISTLE-BLOWER CUSTOMER
>> I HOPE SO.
>> Laura: JUST EXPLAINED THAT
TO OUR VIEWERS, WHY CAN’T YOU
CALL IT THE JUDICIARY?
>> THERE ARE COMMITTEES, I HAVE
JURISDICTION OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AND THE FBI AND WE
WILL CALL EVERYBODY WHO SIGNED
THE FISA WARRANT.
HOW DID THE STATE DEPARTMENT
IGNORE HUNTER BIDEN’S CONFLICT
OF INTEREST AND THINK ABOUT IT,
WHEN JOE BIDEN WAS TALKING TO
THE PARLIAMENT OF THE UKRAINE,
YOU NEED TO END SWEETHEART
DEALS.
DON’T YOU THINK THEY WERE
LAUGHING AT HIM CUSTOMER ASKED
ME WHEN WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE ON MONDAY?
THE DEMOCRATS ROLLING INTO THIS
WHOLE PRIMARY PROCESS AFTER THE
DEBACLE IN THE BUYING AND NOW
WHAT?
>> I DIDN’T DO VERY WELL IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE SO I’M NOT THE GUY
TO ASK BUT SOUTH CAROLINA,
JOE BIDEN WILL WIN THE
SOUTH CAROLINA PRIMARY.
70% OF THE VOTERS WILL BE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN.
HE IS WELL RESPECTED.
A SOCIALIST WILL NOT WIN A
SOUTH CAROLINA PRIMARY.
MAYOR PETE PULLED OFF HER PRETTY
STUNNING THING IN IOWA.
YOU’RE GOING TO HAVE THREE
DIFFERENT WINNERS IN THE FIRST
THREE PRIMARIES.
IMPEACHMENT IS BEHIND US, THE
PRESIDENT IS STRONGER TODAY THAN
BEFORE IMPEACHMENT, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE SEE THIS IS WHAT IT WAS.
AMENDED UP BY PEOPLE WHO CAN’T
ACCEPT THAT HE WON.
THE GOING TO CALL BOLTON, THEY
ARE GOING TO TRY TO DO SOMETHING
BETWEEN NOW AND THE ELECTION
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THEY CAN’T
BEAT HIM.
THE REASON SHE TORE THE SPEECH
UP IS BECAUSE THEY HATE THE
SPEECH.
BUT HERE’S THE GOOD NEWS, YOU
CAN TEAR THE SPEECH UP AT THE
RESULT OF THE SPEECH SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES.
>> Laura: IT IS SO GREAT TO
SEE YOU.
I KNOW WE DON’T LIKE TO KEEP YOU